نعم ، يرجى المضي قدمًا السيد الرئيس إذا
صوتت الهيئة الانتخابية لجو بايدن في 14 ديسمبر ، فهل ستتنازل عن
الانتخابات أه
ثانيًا ، سيكون من الصعب
جدًا التنازل عن ذلك لأننا نعلم أنه
كان هناك تزوير واسع النطاق
لمعرفة ما إذا كان يمكنني الحصول عليه أم لا
هذا الجهاز يتحرك بسرعة
لأن الوقت ليس في صالحنا
كل شيء آخر في جانبنا الحقائق
في جانبنا
كانت هذه عملية احتيال ضخمة
لا ينبغي أن تحدث في هذا البلد ، فنحن
مثل دولة من العالم الثالث
فقط لنكون واضحين إذا
تصوت الهيئة الانتخابية لجو بايدن ،
هل ستتنازل جيدًا إذا فعلوا ذلك ، لقد
ارتكبوا خطأ
لأن هذه الانتخابات كانت عملية احتيال
فقط حتى تفهم أن هذه الانتخابات كانت
عملية تزوير ، أعني أنهم قاموا بضرب بايدن
على أوباما في تصويت أوباما في مناطق مهمة
من حيث
الانتخابات في الولايات المتأرجحة ومع ذلك فهو
يخسر أمام أوباما في كل مكان ،
لكنه هزم أوباما في الولايات المتأرجحة
وهي الولايات التي كانت مهمة
لأغراض الانتخابات ،
لذلك لا يمكنني قول ذلك على الإطلاق  أعتقد
أنه من المحتمل أنهم يحاولون
النظر بينكما ،
لا تجيبوا لا تتحدثوا معي بهذه الطريقة
، أنت مجرد شخص خفيف الوزن
لا تتحدث معي بهذه الطريقة
لا تفعل  تحدث إلي أنا رئيس
الولايات المتحدة لا تتحدث مع
الرئيس بهذه الطريقة على
الإطلاق ، سأذهب بسؤال آخر.